what's the leading cause of death
amongst children in this country and I'm
going to give you a hint it's not drag
show readings to Children correct yes
so what is it I'm presuming you're going
to say it's Firearms no I'm not going to
say it like it's an opinion that's what
it is he's brilliant it'll and this is
the beauty of someone who's really Adept
with comedy he sells to the audience
that he knows what he's talking about I
watch it right away and go bing bing
bing that includes kids 19 years old and
when you eliminate that stat of 16 to 19
it's not even close when you're limited
instead of 14 to 19 and it's all
intergang related when people say hey
it's the leading cause of children
you're right it's a parent and this is
the disservice the media does as a
parent you want to know oh is there a
danger in my bathtub should I not throw
a toaster in there when my twins are you
know learning how to how to play with a
rubber duck that's probably a bad idea
not going okay hold on a second how do
we save kids don't join a gang at 17
years old in Memphis that's the stat
that he throws out but he's so smooth
and collected